How much are you concerned about how
other people view the information that you might
find out? Is this information you're comfortable
sharing with anybody only your family, only yourself?
>> I'm extremely concerned about insurance
companies getting a hold of this information.
And that, that preexisting condition aspect. because
I really, really need my insurance company.
Currently and in the future.
>> So you're most concerned that they would essentially not
they wouldn't carry you any more for.
>> Right. And especially if there were a job
change. And, and we're, we're starting with a new insurance
company. Now, you know, supposedly Obamacare kind of does
away with that, but, what happens when Obama goes away?
>>
[LAUGH]
Any other thoughts specifically about insurance companies from anybody?
>> I just think there's, like she's saying, there's a lot of
potential for some, for people to
take this information and exploit, exploit people
with certain traits. Or certain thing, with certain, yeah, with certain traits
or with people who are confirmed with certain conditions. So I think, yeah.
>> You're the one who would be a potential employer.
You know if they had the information that we
could be out on medical leave a lot for
surgeries, for our children surgeries. I think one thing
that is also different about me than you all is
that there are five of us in our family
with Achondroplasia, so insurance companies are a really big deal
in our house. The thought of losing that and,
and, or my husband losing a potentially a job offer,
if the employer said to himself or herself, hm, this is going to
be a very expensive employee. Our rates are going to go up, and he's
going to be out of work a lot dealing with either his surgery
or one of his four family members. we better not touch this one.